imagine an evolutionary hierarchy
starting with the very simplest thing
that can possibly be imagined something
perhaps mathematical something geometric
but really simple a simple code and it
gets more and more complex in its
emergent behavior and up and up and up
and up and then at one point it gets to
such high levels of complexity but all
built with the same underlying code that
it actually is complex enough to hold as
the substrate the code itself and then
you take this linear hierarchy that's
that's ranked from simple to complex all
the way up to sorts and you just wrap it
into a circle okay we're like the
Ouroboros the simplest part the code is
embedded within the mind of the most
complex part the emergent godhead of
source and in this sense it is logically
consistent all the way through boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we are on
site in the beautiful taupe anga
California we are now going to be
talking about grand unification theory
we have clean or when joining us on the
show hi clay good to be here thank you
for coming out for round two I can't
believe one was almost a year and a half
ago that was like episode 9 this is over
up so 500 now you've been a busy week
we've been busy and everything like at
least a person a day so many diverse
leaders to talk to around the world and
inspire other people to build the future
please the first episode with Klee was
just jam-packed with understanding your
journey understanding quantum gravity
research and what exactly you're working
on here this grand unification theory a
lot about consciousness and the cosmos
as well we're gonna be unpacking that
and even more depth and nuance after
another year and a half of working on
our own projects and building up our own
spiritual avatars when coming back for
the second round blow Sedona please
background clear wood is a global leader
and grand unification theory be seen
together space time with quantum
mechanics he's the founder of quantum
gravity Research Institute and you can
find the link in the bottle blow to
quantum gravity research org all right
clear let's start things off by talking
about source we come from the same
source tell us about your relationship
with that well I I have this view of
what source is that's I call the
Ouroboros model and it's an idea that
says imagine if God or the collective
consciousness of the universe
self-actualized itself created itself
and so what we think is that there is a
very simple primordial space-time code
it's abstract so it's made of
information and information has to have
a substrate
whether it's the atoms and your memory
but if we say that atoms are information
then information needs a substrate so
one substrate for information is a mind
but nobody knows really what a mind is
because no one can define consciousness
in a way that academics can agree on
with consensus but we do know mind
exists right because we are pretty sure
we're conscious we just don't know how
it comes to be even a peep in a
biological might we're not sure how it
emerges from the laws of physics but
what if this were possible that the
universe is evolutionary in nature where
simple things self organize into more
complex systems which self organize yet
again into ever more complex systems
until one day a system becomes mind like
and like a human and and it just keeps
going from there and then the mind like
entities can begin self-organizing but
what if the ultimate level of the
self-organization is so vast at some
level that it is a mind like thing
capable of holding within its mind a
very simple
primitive space-time code which is just
purely abstract and then it plays that
code to create itself now people have a
problem with this if they're stuck in
the paradigm of linear causality where a
causes B which causes C
but what if a could cause B which caused
C which caused a which caused B which
caused C and so on so that's the
Ouroboros concept where the code the
simplest thing lives within the mind of
God or the collective consciousness and
the collective consciousness emerges
from the code just as our consciousness
has but way beyond us so if such a thing
existed I mean in physics and science we
have to take things on with a form of
faith so the faith is all right this
this theory that seems to look more
probable than this theory but we still
call it a theory always because we're
not admitting that it's absolutely true
we're saying it's probably true but you
can have spiritual theories as well that
you use your mind and you say well this
is probably true right so if you if you
can imagine that such a thing could be
true maybe it is and then maybe you
could play around with it by trying to
tap into it you wouldn't know exactly
how you'd have to sort of freestyle it
you know or you could follow the the
free stylings of other people right
teachers Jesus Buddha right but maybe
there's no one true and only freestyle
maybe there's a million in one ways to
access to resonate with this flow this
source this god this collective
consciousness or spirit that's how I
look at it and so I I try I play around
I try different things I I manipulate
the chemicals in my body through what I
eat and how I exercise how my hormones
changed my body play around with that
sometimes I'll find a sweet spot where I
feel
I've tried plant medicines you know I've
tried meditating you know breath work
flow tanks and so each person finds
their own way to tap into this source
and when you tap in and you kind of get
the feel for it it seems that there's no
limit to how deeply and profoundly you
can tap in but you got a start you got
to tap in to start all right when we
take our first fall from grace from
source the first the sort of first
principle this first urge is to be like
how do I divinely commune back with with
source and there's an infinite amount of
ways to do that and so then we have a
process of then self work that we have
to do in order to figure out how we
clear our channels and make it easier
for us to go and commune with source
what works best for us and then also
there's this aura borås component a
source of how you see it so we have this
this DS this deployment of creation
which has these in a sense these very
more simple lines of code and then as it
complexity evolves and it evolves more
and it keeps evolving keeps evolving the
minds evolve and then the minds evolve
like a massive neural network a massive
a massive array of minds that are then
doing things like realizing that they
came from source then those Minds also
do the full circle they make source A to
B to C to a is that yeah and what are we
doing when the minds become complex
enough that they themselves make source
and then the cycle happens what is that
so so taking a lot of what you said I
see that the my viewpoint is that God or
source cannot exist without creation
existing because it emerged
through creation that is it the the the
sub that the neural network right the
topological substrate for source is all
is is the everything and and is and it
is the complexity that comes from the
everything so for example a human being
with its incredible ability for abstract
thought which can cause problems or
create beauty that is very complex as a
complex system and then the the the
tribal global emergent constructs of
economies belief systems language is the
internet a giant neural network of
information all of these things are
super organisms that are even yet more
complex than an individual human mm-hm
and so so so as as its kind of like the
aboriginals this idea of a great dream
within the great mind of a great dreamer
and all of the separate story lines and
individuals in human lives are subplot
source or sub stories sub programs
within this global program but but in
this story the Ouroboros philosophy each
sub program is contributing to the
evolution and the expansion of the
collective consciousness of source at
all times in everything that it does we
are all different colored paints
different paintbrushes making different
paint strokes and different size of
strokes or different instruments playing
different notes in the collective
symphony of creation and then when this
when this topological neural network
which we'll get to in a bit when this
gets comp when this gets complex enough
it then makes a C goes to a and we make
another creation well you have to resist
the temptation of linear causality right
because in that sense
there existed linear causality okay
teach me yeah yeah so so if a cos B cos
C caused a cos B cos C well what caused
what first okay it is no first what
number is is no first what number is
first on the o'clock three o'clock four
o'clock first right well just because
there's no first doesn't mean there is
not a rank okay
what was more complex in in
consciousness you or some some some
descendant that existed some predecessor
of yours that existed you know of three
billion years ago a more primitive
organism that's right in your
evolutionary family tree well you are
and going forward in time there can be
there can be beings that exists now in
Einstein space-time at least exert a
stand present all exist in the same
object and so we're just one point on
this evolutionary imagine an
evolutionary hierarchy starting with the
very simplest thing that can possibly be
imagined something perhaps mathematical
something geometric but really simple a
simple code and it gets more and more
complex in its emergent behavior and up
and up and up and up and then at one
point it gets to such high levels of
complexity but all built with the same
underlying code that it actually is
complex enough to hold as the substrate
the code itself and then you take this
linear hierarchy that's that's ranked
from simple to complex all the way up to
source and you just wrap it into a
circle okay we're like the Ouroboros the
simplest part the code is embedded
within the mind of the most complex part
the emergent godhead of source and in
this sense it is logically consistent
all the way through were a child who you
know children love to ask questions to
priests and physics
we're inevitably each will say a child
that is a question I cannot answer right
but in this viewpoint you can stop at
any point on the circle of the orbitals
Boros and say where did that emerge from
right we can say well where did DNA
emerge from we can actually tell some
stories about that through science yes
and we can say well where would our
super smart lineage right come from
those people after us we say will us
obviously right where so and what and
and what emerges from them and so on and
and so that's that's kind of trying to
connect as best I can to what you said
yeah that was a those a great visual of
the this sort of hierarchical from
simplicity all the way up to complexity
in linearly and then wrapping that
around rainbow or a Boris that was great
and then also just the question then for
I guess for us and I think for a lot of
people that may be watching would be
something along the lines of well then
when we go back back back back back back
back back back to our source well then
where did that source come from how many
times has this cycle happened is it all
just happening and how do we know that
or we just okay with it just being as is
and just being that about it there was
there was a movie with Ethan Hawke
called predestination and in the movie
predestination he was his he was his
father's son and his son's father and he
was his sons he it was this bizarre
triangle but the thing about this movie
is that you could watch it over and over
and over and you cannot find a logical
inconsistency because in the film they
explained exactly how it makes sense
that he's his his father's father right
and how his son is his father and yet at
the same time his son as his son now I'm
not going to try to explain that because
it's a mind-bending movie but again your
question asks
whoa what created source right your real
question was about are there cycles and
I think yeah there could be cycles I
have an intuition there are cycles but
even if there weren't cycles you can
still take one cycle and you can say
where did God emerge well God emerged in
the same way that you emerged from
simple things okay fine then where does
the simplest thing at the beginning of
it all emerge from where does it live it
lives within the mind of God and because
this is one form of circular reasoning
that is not problematic generally
circular reasoning is a is a problem
this is actually brutally consistent
logically right but it does require the
rejection of linear causality where
because you can accept that the code
could be in the mind of God right that's
not a problem and you can even accept
that the mind of God can emerge from a
code because you're kind of godlike
compared to a grain of salt right and
it's really quite remarkable that you're
here asking me these questions this is
very heady stuff right and so if you
just take remarkable Ness many orders of
magnitude beyond you and your
amazingness that a bunch of quarks and
electrons self-organized into Alan Ness
and take it further and then when you
get far enough to where you can accept
that it is a complex enough entity to
hold in an origin code a Genesis code
then you have to ask yourself well wait
a minute why couldn't the great dreamer
have dreamed itself through through this
code theoretic you know evolutionary
build-up and you can't come up with a
reason why not like there will be no
logical deal-killer
okay yeah and so then maybe a main
principle for those that are attempting
to do their best including myself and so
many others are just about just really
trying to embody this style of wisdom is
both of course just trying to divinely
commune ourselves with source but also
the notion of this non-linearity and
living non linearly yes living
circularly
Oh see this style yeah and I'm talking
about when how to tap into that so I go
to Hana a lot in Hawaii because there's
a lot of and a lot of subtle energy
let's call it
that's very palpable for me there and I
can get healthy quick there or I can get
you know connections non-local downloads
and ideas there and I really tapped in a
few months ago there to a story that
works for me that I finally get it and
it was very otherworldly in terms of how
it was shown to me it just felt like it
was some kind of it felt spiritual okay
like something giving me you know
insight so here's what it was think
about this word centering to center
yourself right
so in chakra theory right we have these
seven primary chakras and it's really
one in the middle three up and three
down so the one in the middle is kind of
in the middle so it's special in that
regard and and and and the idea and
those meditations that seek to kind of
integrate you and just make you into a
nice whole flow it's about finding this
you know imagining this resonance
between these energetic centers right so
if this is one story and thought and
theory but take something like that and
combine it with time okay so follow that
idea say I'm gonna literally kind of
imagine myself in my heart like maybe
touch your chest and just kind of be
like okay I'm just kind of feeling a
little emotional I'm in my heart right
whatever it feels and then just try to
go down and feel the rest of your body
down to your feet and up to your head
and then go further and try to just go
out and picture from the top you know
the center of the Sun and the center of
the Milky Way and just get really
connected and just kind of vaguely
connect to the whole universe but as you
go bigger and bigger so we're in
stained our geometry and then go down
the other way and imagine you know
connecting to the center of the earth
and then connecting to small things you
know like molecules and the cells cells
in our cells in your body yeah start
their cells then molecules then atoms
you know then whatever you think quarks
and electrons are and just try to do
this big to small but be in the middle
you're going really big like the galaxy
and then you go in really small and you
and you're going down to the center of
the earth and you're going up and then
add in time and you'll and you'll
complete it so now imagine yourself last
year and just try to tune in to the dude
mmm you from last year mm-hmm as far as
you can go and where you end where you
stop remembering like when you get to
yourself at nine years old make it up
here is better to make it up because
that's an anchor to connecting to the
non-local information just imagine
yourself at night just be like I imagine
myself at night I'm connecting to the
little guy right and and in going all
the way back to your birth just kind of
decide that you're accepting every event
yes
you know the [ __ ] in school who is
mean or the girl who rejected you or
this person who hurt you but you know
take the good the bad and just say I
love it all because it was a ride yeah
and it led me to where I am now it's
been interesting you know and then and
then go the other way now the other way
mmm it's harder to remember it's easier
to remember the past and then the future
but remember they both exist so then say
well I'm gonna hook up with myself in a
year and just be like hey dude what's up
I hope you're still alive physically I
mean they're still alive you know and
connect and connect and then and then
shoot it out further from both
directions go beyond yourself at birth
and try to connect to anything you want
to imagine all the way back to the Big
Bang now you can do this as slow or as
fast as you want however much detail
point is just to feel it and then go out
really far in time so you're going
backwards in time to the Big Bang and it
comes up with and spans through your
life like a deck of playing cards and it
gets here to the now
again that's the center in that's the
center of time for you the now and then
go up all the way to this unimaginable
emergent conscious universe that is of
God like you know consciousness and and
then picture as a metaphor the largest
living thing known in the universe which
is California seek help these things
root down into rocks at the bottom of
the Pacific on the shore and they grow
up and up and up and up until they get
to this big plume on the surface of the
ocean they are the tallest thing on the
planet a mile they can be perhaps that
tall I don't know the exact I only know
they're the tallest thing but the ocean
because of the you know the tides from
the moon and the wind on the surface
it's always waving which makes the water
down below it wave and this rubbery kelp
it waves and then it has these big
floppy leaves along the way that then
just harmoniously flow and try to
envision this stack of playing cards
there's a card which is Alan at age one
year old and one minute and one second
and just boom that's there and then
another in the ocean it's this giant
stack of playing cards as tall as the
Empire State Building of every moment of
your life yeah but it waves that you're
totally in love with and very good bad
yeah yeah and it has a consciousness in
this story right this is all story
science of story spiritualism is story
right so in this story allow the playing
card deck to wave and Anjali and so this
kelp represents the time domain and it
has an intelligence I am proposing that
that pattern can be encoded over time
for example if you've seen a laser show
at a lays there like a beautiful laser
show at a concert or a lays area they
can have an image of a little girl
chasing a video of a little girl chasing
a butterfly
and her father is running from the other
direction all in this laser show picture
but if you freeze it in one moment you
find out the truth which is that there
was only one tiny dot with the laser on
it at that one moment only that and only
by moving it fast over time in a
strategic way does it give you this
information over time of the little girl
and so imagine yeah that there is
information like an uber consciousness
or super consciousness that flows
through your entire life from birth all
the way through way past where you're at
now and just let's cap it off there and
say is it more likely that the meta
consciousness that flows through every
moment of Alan's life could perhaps be
more conscious than the momentary
consciousness in this two seconds of
Alan's mind and his consciousness now so
we pretend yes okay and then we go out
even further and so much help versus the
slice of a card of moment exactly the
law the whole kelp versus a slice of the
kelp yeah and so by taking that out
through space from the smallest to the
largest and and the most complex to the
least complex and through time from the
Big Bang to some omega point that is my
idea of source and because it waves and
I have this vision that it waves tune
into the wave and you won't know how to
do it by strict instructions because
science hasn't figured out the exact
mathematics of that particular wave so
you got to do it with kind of intuitive
you know autonomic purposes starting
with intention you just say I want hey
wave if you're supposedly intelligent
you know maybe you are help me the tune
into you do like help me to tune in and
you can get some help
one of all the guided meditations and
whatnot that I've had the chance to sit
through like so many more people should
be using that one till they really can
never go wrong with kelp and and also
this lets practice of that was such a
good way for people at home wherever
you're watching listening from do that
practice of tuning in to the body and
then going from the body to the macro
going from to the micro and then also
doing your whole deck of cards in the
past or a deck of cards forward imagine
yourself as that kelp and then just
tapping into that source way yes that's
that is happening yeah that's really
good this is why Kleiza synthesist and
like you can tell there's you one has to
take a lot of of the most critical
questions in life like the most pressing
questions about life and study them for
a long time and then piece together a
really good story to be able to make
this make sense it's oh it's so good if
we continue at this pace we're going to
talk for seven hours so I
I do want to hit a couple of these other
thoughts before we get to number gence
theory one of them is that is there is
this something that you also embody as
truth this notion that so many
indigenous people around the world are
saying that our disconnection from
nature from source is the reason why we
have so many of the issues in our world
yeah I am I am into this idea called a
strange attractor and so in emergence
theory which is what me and my
colleagues work on the universe is code
theoretic which is probably a sterile
word code for language right because
music is language poetry is language
but C++ is language - so if reality is
based on a code perhaps since reality
appears to be geometric perhaps it can
be a geometric code or language and all
languages are codes traffic and meaning
right for example if you want to get
high a high paid job in Silicon Valley
you have to figure out how to use a
given code to write a compression
algorithm with fewer lines of code
because that'll that'll make the company
money and in poetry the name of the game
is to use double entendres and really
elegant compact usages of words in other
words the pack maximal meaning yes
within a given lights you know
expression of code and so I don't know
if many codes that don't work like that
even DNA is incredibly compact and
efficient and so if it is meaning that
the universe is trying to maximize then
it would make sense that things get more
complex like the physicists tell us
cosmologists would tell us that shortly
after the Big Bang there were no atoms
there was something called a quark-gluon
plasma yeah and it was very boring and
very homogeneous so if you knew the
court gluon plasma density at one
section you knew the rest you don't need
to know anymore and then things began to
self-organize and we and we arrived
after that at the early hydrogen
universe now it's more organized because
now the quarks and you know the
fundamental subatomic elements of
self-organized and then we and then we
self-organized into an 81 stable atom
universe so 81 letters so to speak then
those began self-organizing and so on
and so on until we have a universe today
with immeasurably higher complexity with
biospheres and then molecules that can
encode petabytes of information such as
DNA and so when important self
organizing events exist in the future
the way that the code works is we're
statistically drawn to it the way a
strange attractor in a chaotic system
which is a little accidental kernel of
order and complexity within an ocean of
chaos and noise and the strange
attractor begins orchestrating and
coaxing the rest of the system to become
more organized to attract toward its
organization so imagine that strange
attractors are high-impact informational
events of complexity important events
like a trance transcendent moment for a
species like the species landing on the
moon or discovering the ultimate theory
of everything something important they
would tend to draw so I think indigenous
people but many things draw in this way
and that's this idea of the kelp where
we think that the flow over time in this
deck of playing cards is so that the
events that happen here when you were 15
years old happened just right so that
the events could unfold to more
complexity and meaning when when you're
25 years old and you can't see that
until later so I think indigenous people
could tap into this flow right and
attach that though that of metaphors
that helped them you know whatever the
stories are and that that gets in you
know culturally embedded and and into
the very behavior of the of the group
and it even gets into genetic expression
according to your modern genetics theory
you know we're where our traumas and the
things that happen to us collectively
getting encoded or expressed genetically
so tapping in is again that what
indigenous people have been doing
tapping into source is is much more
natural and coherent with the future
evolution of what the global system is
over time is trying to emerge but humans
because of our powerful intellect and
ability of for abstract thought for
example I could worry about whether I
paid enough taxes last year
and whether I'm gonna go bankrupt as a
result and and my daughter is gonna
become a pole dancer because I can't
send her to college okay
these stories right just hilarious
stories tragic stories we and so what
runs the world today this materialistic
generally atheistic paradigm
prioritizing money and and greed all
based on the conversion of trapped solar
energy to fuel our society right through
fossil fuels this whole thing is
completely a house of cards
they were almost at the limit of its
purpose and I actually think it has
served the purpose for example without
that having happened that whole paradigm
we wouldn't be able to communicate with
your followers right now exactly led to
this it did but it served its purpose
and we need to now learn something from
our ancestors who were more tapped in we
don't have to take all their stories we
can pick and choose from the stories but
the fundamental practice that they were
doing was tapping into the flow they
were tapped into the Celt wave yeah and
then it's it's as though than they are
saying that hey tap into the kelp wave
more so that we can solve some of the
problems that if not all of the problems
that we have going on in our world and
it's also great to hear you talking
about the TV ology of the species you do
you think that that's kind of the
purpose of the grand human experiment is
to maximize meaning is that that's the
purpose of source yeah maximize
creativity I personally have a growing
eerie suspicion that humans may
historically be playing an important
part in the evolution of the universe
because my Ouroboros viewpoint requires
a level of complexity of where we're at
now at some point in the evolution you
have to have some animal that is capable
of getting off the planet and creating a
doubling algorithm to spread its high
four
of of complex systems which is itself
and its technology and its philosophies
and then if that species if that genie
gets out of the bottle it can double
doubling algorithms can just sneak up on
you I think we talked about the metaphor
first surgically made it really clear
that we are a massive anomaly all right
and that's why we may be because once
you do go and do the doubling get out
into the cosmos you take over the cosmos
yeah so the reaper argument that we're
not the first is that we've discovered
that life can exist on earth in very
inhospitable places sulfuric acid at
very high temperatures and very cold and
and we've also discovered in recent
years that there seem to be planets
orbiting a large number of suns and
stars and we also know logically that
those planets that are at have the right
distance those are going to have water
so it would be irrational to even the
moons in our own Enceladus you're right
yeah so however what is what what is the
argument on the other side that humans
maybe the first form of ultra high
consciousness capable of populating the
rest of the universe with consciousness
such that Beth's consciousness can
network and begin growing inwards and
envelop everything as a collective
consciousness so the geology is for us
to be able to propagate out meaning
widespread meaning yes consciousness is
meaning yes so to be able to be source
experiencing itself the more source that
experiences itself is the purpose right
and but the other side of the argument
is just by way of review but very
quickly is that evolutionary biology
abhors what humans have become it
generally snuffs animals out that become
20% faster smarter or stronger than
where it is in its predator-prey niche
but humans got away with that
evolutionary biology was not able yet to
snuff us out and if we if we get off if
we learn to use our high consciousness
to get along with evolutionary biology
which is concerned about symbiosis
across the whole biosphere then that'll
be good or if we continue being stupid
about it and we get off planet then our
descendants can can go out but I do I do
have this and then we also haven't heard
any other species so far manipulating
the electromagnetic spectrum and we you
know looked around in the SETI program
so you know there's arguments for both
sides I've thought about it a lot my
intuition is that we may turn out it it
wouldn't be arrogant to say it would
just be a guess to say well there's no
good reason why we couldn't be the first
and if so our responsibility may be
great massive massive the most important
thing to preserve it propagate it out
more meaning more creativity more
experience Klee is this rock life the
human experiment on this specific Rock
we're talking about the purpose of it is
there are we acting as just vessels
channels transducers for a higher level
source messaging to come through us and
id8 and create itself in the physical
world that we live in and what is that
what is this that comes through us if so
what is it and is there good and evil
and where do those come from and then
how do these play out like a big board
game on the planet so I think that with
this code theoretic view of reality that
reality is a language expressing one of
the the foundational rule in a code is
that you must have free will that is the
syntactical freedom of the code nothing
can strictly determine it can't
determine how it's going to play out and
so what if free will is actually
necessary to even define consciousness
what is my consciousness right now in
this moment I'm not sure but I know that
it has something to do with the king
catenation of thoughts that I choose to
think about and then the order within
that concatenation is this thought you
know like I wonder what it's going to be
for dinner tonight with all the whole
package and so so I think I think that
that that meaning is the goal of the
universe and that in order to recognize
meaning you need consciousness in order
to define consciousness freewill has to
be part of it it's very almost trivially
clear and so nothing versus it for it
all to just be predetermined and just
playing itself out which wouldn't be as
much of a fun creation right it would it
right and so are we truly controlled by
anything and why would there be good and
evil so does does good and evil have
anything to do with enlightenment
mmm-hmm
no why what is enlightenment to me
enlightenment is the dissolution of Maya
ignorance illusion and delusion but I
don't need to choose to serve others and
and and have a life exemplifying love in
order to have awareness right I I can
write one can rise from the Maya and
have exceptional understanding and by
their own free will still choose to be
primarily of service to self and if
that's reasonable right then ahead of us
in our descendant lineage we would have
advanced consciousnesses that
are selfish and serve themselves and we
would have other advanced
consciousnesses that specialize in love
and service to others why because that's
what they chose it's their own reasons
doesn't matter why it's what it's just
what they chose so and are they looking
back at our kindergarten planet Earth
and going like hey guys you're almost
keep going there in a feedback loop so
that nothing exists without the playing
card you don't it you're constantly
influenced by yourself when you were 15
and you are influenced by yourself when
you are 45 yes and so one area of the
evolution can seek to over dominate the
the other side right like if you and
your selfish moment right now I decide
to commit suicide well then you've
killed some possibility of yourself
existing tomorrow right maybe yourself
in a month didn't want to do that had
plans right if it could have existed in
you and so perhaps there can be advanced
consciousnesses that are in some sense
forward in time from us but now like in
the movie arrival they live across time
their consciousness is defined as not
being in one moment at a time
and let's say they're jerks from our
perspective of how we value love and
service and they want to manipulate
things in the world today to keep it
selfish into the paradigm of fear
because that better establishes their
reality at least probabilistically in
the future but if everything were to go
all mushy gushy love peace and chicken
grease let's hold hands kumbaya the kind
of world I want to see then the
probability for a lot of those being
very powerful in the future is more
limited or there are fewer of them so if
I were them if I were the service to
self advanced potentialities in the
future or realities in the future I
would probably try to get trump
reelected and I would create a lot of
fear going on
would help create the Maya and the
distraction to keep people in darkness
longer because when you do wake up and
become enlightened the truth is you tend
to be more loving because fear pretty
much goes away even though it's
technically possible that you can still
be enlightened and choose selfishness
and so I think that they would have
self-preserving interest to keep the
world in a state of fear and Maya and
and materialism for as long as possible
and other guys would have a similar
interest to do the opposite maybe not so
much to preserve themselves but because
they are haven't achieved pure states of
service to others and so they're doing
it out of service so they help us and
we're not controlled by any of them we
just choose who to be influenced by we
will collaborate with you said in the
first time that we talk together
creativity is synthesizing combinatorics
I really like that a lot you are
synthesis yourself you can type take and
combine who is it 16 people around the
table and the different what is utility
an arrangement 20 to be only gonna be
arrangements of 16 people around a table
so that gives you an idea of how many if
you can combine different disparate
fields into new ideas you can really
rock it the edge of knowledge forward
and let's talk emergence theory so
what's been going on the last year and a
half so we have we have space-time we
have quantum mechanics we're like how do
these things work together and this has
been the grand dilemma of the last we
had 100 about a hundred years almost
yeah okay alright and you guys are like
ok so there's an idea of pixelation yeah
yeah at this see most people are
familiar with atoms and then you break
down the atom into the world at least
the protons and neutrons in the nucleus
down into quarks but electrons are not
broken down into quarks
quarks and electrons in the current
world view are the are dimensionless
points called point particles and their
fundamental particles so there's they
are not in modern physics the current
theory is that they are not built of
anything else
they are primordial okay they are not
built of anything else yet the Planck
volume is still makes up quarks and
makes up electrons
well the Planck volume is is not assumed
with the fundamental particle view the
Planck volume is a is a conjecture
it's a conjecture that comes through
deductive logic using quantum mechanics
so if you just start using quantum
mechanics then you realize because of
the equations that a length because
quantum mechanics at least the
Copenhagen interpretation says something
doesn't exist unless it's observed right
and so if you follow all that logic then
you get to this point where you cannot
have a length shorter than some length
of volume less than a some volume and a
time that's shorter than the plunk time
so the Planck volume the Planck length
from the plunk time so I can try to
simplify the request the importance of
the quest so the importance of the quest
is that right now the world is is it an
unprecedented like there's no historical
precedence we don't really know what's
going to happen all we know is that
technology is exponentially increasing
the population is growing and global
warming is accelerating and along with a
lot of other issues right but so we
don't really know what's going to happen
we do know that oftentimes understanding
nature better helps for example when we
discovered some equations on a
blackboard in Denmark it was the quantum
mechanics equations and those equations
led to the Internet you cannot have the
internet cannot have digital computers
without having first
discovered the equations of quantum
mechanics which is something about
nature and then the internet helps
people right there's a lot of good and
freedom of infirmity it's hard for a
despot or a controller of information to
control information like they could in
the good old days when there was only
you know three national broadcast
networks and a few local newspapers in
each city you could control things
easier and even easier earlier in time
right so what good might come if we get
the whole enchilada the whole theory of
everything and so what is the theory of
everything
so theory we have a theory of space and
time I mean if you think about
everything right excluding emergent
things like consciousness and
socioeconomics and whatnot in chemistry
right those are all the emergent but if
you go down to the fundamental things
yes you have the you have particles
fundamental particles not not atoms
those are not fundamental you have these
quarks and electrons and neutrinos right
and photons the fundamental particles
and then they play out their self
organizing and playing out in this stuff
called space and time
so the theory of space and time is
general relativity and it was weird
because it tells us that the past
continues to exist and the future exists
that was weird because before 1905 when
special relativity came out before that
scientists thought that the future does
not exist and the past also does not
exist and that the only thing that
exists is that is the continually moving
now so that was interesting and then we
discovered something even more weird
than that in quantum mechanics which is
the realization that reality is not like
the Newtonian clockwork universe where a
few knew in precise detail the starting
condition of something you could predict
every time what's going to happen like
dominoes like if you could see at that
level of detail turned out that was
false and that there's this bizarre myth
almost just just misty
world of probabilities and that it's
about information so quantum mechanics
at a very deep level is about the
information that one can know about a
physical system through observation or
measurement and unlike all of the other
theories such as electromagnetism or
general relativity quantum mechanics is
the odd guy
it's the anomaly it's a theory that
doesn't come exactly with a model right
that you can understand why statistics
like there are thermal dynamic
statistics but those statistics from
thermal dynamics come from this buildup
of a full set of machinery in the model
quantum mechanics is different we got
all this data from experiments that was
the weird wonky data where things are
going are behaving not like the
classical universe who just amassed that
data and then this genius guy Werner
Heisenberg realizes that it matches up
with some math class that he took in
university and he laid down his version
of quantum mechanics and then few years
later Schrodinger laid down his version
and they were found to be the same but
it's really bizarre because nobody
understands what the hell is causing
these statistics it's kind of like it's
kind of like a car and you're looking at
the hood you have no idea what's under
the hood with this one theory but every
other theory we know what's under the
hood and so you got the theory quantum
mechanics that's very powerful led to
the Internet but what we don't but that
we don't really understand what it means
richard fineman said nobody understands
what quantum mechanics means they he
said perfectly he said no one
understands quantum mechanics right he
meant that under the hood and then this
theory of space-time and to make it
worse the theory of space-time general
relativity clearly and vehemently says
that quantum mechanics is wrong certain
axioms and fundamental precepts and
that's a problem because quantum
mechanics seems to at least be partly
true because it creates this technology
and it matches up with you know
experiments and then quantum mechanics
strictly says
at general relativity is wrong so
they're they they they imply one another
wrong so clearly there's there's a
problem we don't understand quantum
mechanics and we don't understand why
these theories are saying one another
are incorrect
now to combine the theories modern
people outside of our group are have
decided that space and time may be
pixelated and what we do here at quantum
gravity research is the way we pixelate
space-time so if it's pixelated then the
particles would be patterns or
perturbations or ripples within this
pixelated pattern so you start with
space-time as the fundamental thing and
then the ripples are the different types
of particles and then they interact okay
so we we pixelate it in a logical way so
if the Large Hadron Collider in Geneva
Switzerland they collide particles
together and that you know they've done
the same thing at earlier particle
colliders in the United States we would
amass this data very very expensive to
acquire data and that led to this
extension or expansion of quantum
mechanics combined with this particle
accelerator data which is called the
standard model of particle physics it's
the most powerful theory that mankind
has physics theory and it explains quark
interactions how you know how one
particle will become another and it
turns out that way that everything
becomes something else and interacts
maps to this algebra which is called a
li algebra so it's a these are higher
dimensional Li algebras and those
algebra Tsar vector algebra z' and so
they're associated with crystals or
lattices but just higher dimensional
it's like a checkerboard but in higher
dimensional space and then what we do is
we transform that lattice by projective
geometry to a lower dimension such as 3d
and we get a mathematical object called
a quasi crystal and a quasi crystal is
different than a crystal in so far as it
being a language a language is pretty
simple to define it's a fine
a set of objects like a checkerboard
that squares black squares and red
squares the second thing is that has to
have strict rules on how you can arrange
the objects checkerboard has strict
rules you have to go red black red black
right and you got it you got to do it
you know
eight across well the third component of
a language is that there must be
syntactical freedom within the rules
such that you have a little wiggle room
and that that that's not what a
checkerboard is but English is that it's
against the law for me to say the dog
ran cat but I do not have to say the dog
ran fast so you have to follow the rules
and I also can't introduce a new word
that doesn't even exist in the language
I can't say the god the dog rat ran
shaman even thank you yeah right against
the law right we wouldn't be using
English so so a quasi crystal is a more
mathematical code that has those three
qualities and and because it Maps back
to the higher-dimensional Li algebra as
it maps back to the most powerful
unification theory we have which is
unifying everything except for gravity
but but except for space and time but
because the expression of the quasi
crystal code itself is our space-time
background we get space-time and the
particle interactions all unifying under
a dynamic animation if you will in this
quasi crystalline space where all the
interactions can be mapped right back up
to the standard model of particle
physics gauge symmetry equation so it's
very promising and and kind of rigorous
okay so there's a way to take how the
elementary particles are dynamically at
play in this predictive pixilated
existence that we're in and there's a
way to to take and make it's a
projection of the of them in you know in
it we're projecting them into a higher
or lower dimensional or Demand lower
dimensional quasicrystal
okay which then that that then is the
load that that is the than pixelation
that we're talking about is the yeah
quasi crystal yes it's like the lattice
it's like a yeah we would call it a
quasi periodic lattice cuz it's not it's
not Syriac yeah it's like a lattice or a
neural network a neural yeah okay but
made of information so one would not it
would be a false question to say well
wait a minute what are those little
pixels made out of you can ask the
question but the answer would be
it's made of information made up and for
about one can ask what is the
information made up okay and then one
could say name any information that does
not require a consciousness so there's
so so clearly the name what is it made
of well it's made of consciousness
recognizing Klee yeah or you could say
what it what are the if we'd zoom down
below the clerks and down into this
Planck scale abstract mathematical space
of lines and angles and shapes
what are those made of then one would
say well they're actually the same thing
that you would say if you picture a
square in your mind right now it's a
square I can see the 90-degree angles
yes what's it made of what do you mean
what it's a made up it's in my mind it's
made it's made of I don't know what it's
made out of my conscious made of my con
because you can't see it's made of the
atoms of your mind can you
so cause so the caustic quasi will cause
it you repetitive Chris hug would you
call so are they up to quasi lattice
yeah because he doesn't repeat it's it's
oh yeah it's not periodic it's not
period because in the quasi lattice is
not periodic because as different
elementary particles are making no way
it's because the projection of the
crystal is irrational it's based on a
golden ratio based angle and when you
use that angle you collapse you collapse
it down to the symmetry called H 3 which
is icosahedron symmetry and you have a
very small set of fund
shapes like letters like geometric
letters and the way that those geometric
shapes can be arranged is by strict
rules but there's syntactical freedom
within the rules so what you can do is
you can arrange them one way set that to
the side
arrange them another way set that to the
side and another way and then now you
have an ordered set like a 35 millimeter
film like the deck of playing cards with
the uber the superconsciousness flowing
through it so the quasi lattice is is is
what makes up everything in the lowest
dimensional level and then that is
that's that is you can project that
upwards to make standard this the part
of the elementary particles could
recover it yeah coughs so that if you in
a sense if you're looking at a shape
like a cube like a cube made of sticks
but it's a cube it's a wireframe cube if
you look at it you're with one eye
you're seeing something as flat as a
National Geographic photograph but your
eye your brain has an algorithm that
extrudes or unfolds that two-dimensional
shape into your knowledge of a
three-dimensional shape right just like
right now you're you have a that this
knowledge that might at a point on my
nose is further this way in
three-dimensional space than my ear but
you really are at least through one eye
seen just a flat image so mathematically
through trigonometry we can take the
mathematics of the quasi crystal
animation where reality is playing out
and map back to this hyper dimensional
crystal that's part of alley algebra
that maps to the gauge symmetry
equations of the standard model of
particle physics okay yeah that last
part yeah how does let you go with that
last part as though as the bit there
okay so yeah so the quasi lattice and
then that maps to Li algebra yeah which
is part of gauge symmetry connects you
to rigorous physics so that you can go
beyond just hand waving Wu talk and you
can late
rigorous equations that unifies
space-time and particle physics okay and
then where's the team at with that so
we've been at it for ten years
yep and I don't have an advanced college
degree so I'm surprised that I found
myself in this situation my I'm an
entrepreneur you know and but I walked
out of my building ten years ago and I
never came back I've been back to that
building twice in ten years so for ten
years I've been working full-time with
PhD mathematicians and physicists to
help me interpret and make rigorous
these understandings that I have been
getting and you know I get them just by
thinking and visualizing and working
really hard you know just reading
thousands of papers you know scientific
papers arguing debating talking about
mathematics just doing it but I feel
like I have a cheat like an X Factor
like I'm a I'm a maybe I am smart and
creative but it's not enough to even if
I were that's not enough to justify how
we could be so lucky as to have stumbled
upon the correct approach to unification
physics and the X Factor that I suspect
is that I feel like sometimes the best
description of why I can say guys we
need to use quasi crystal mathematics or
we need or here is how this math works
is it's almost as though like it feels
like I remember it but that even that is
not the best word it's a better word a
better way to describe it is imagine
that a percentage of your subconscious
can be by located to a different time
yes so you don't even know it
it's just sure does feel that way yeah
now if
you were it would make you a little bit
Spacey er down here because let's say
20% of your subconscious has just been
sequestered right hijack to be linked
and be almost white like remote viewing
just yeah I located and maybe it's
something like that but whatever it is
you know I can't if it turns out to be
successful and change the world I won't
be able to just take complete credit by
saying oh yeah I got lucky or or or or
I'm really smart or creative I'll have
to always be clear that I feel like it
was a collaboration between people from
the future right what and they may not
be humanoid yeah if they do not born
here and they don't have our DNA but
they don't have our exact coding of our
type of DNA but but it would make sense
right the advanced beings of
consciousness from the future that wants
us put self potentiate their view of a
collaborative loving service to others
cooperative universe they would try to
look for willing teammates or
collaborators in their ancestral tree
who are just crazy enough have just
enough lack of risk aversion yes or have
whatever mental problems
you know like I'm an ad D type of person
I have a little bit of dyslexia so I
rearrange things in a strange way to
create synergistic moments for you to
find the PhD mathematicians and
physicists yeah so everything is a setup
in one way or another so when I think
about well why did I spend time becoming
an entrepreneur to make money well I
can't do this without money because I'm
not a one-man show I have a team without
without these PhDs
there's no way I could do this by myself
and if they're expensive yeah of course
right so it's when you look back you
kind of see this beautiful thing
unfolding over many years where you
can't see the purpose until you look
back and then we
you do look back you wonder well to what
extent was it orchestrated yeah yeah and
that also leads us to what you were
saying a little bit ago about the
benevolence yeah from the future at play
so then where's the team at I'm late so
yeah where's look at the timeline is
that so that was ten years ago when I
left the business world and most of the
ten years has been this slow process of
osmosis just gathering ideas becoming
intuitively attracted to this or that
math or these metaphors you know like
cymatics for example just as a metaphor
a physical thing cymatics gives me a lot
of intuitions that that I can use to say
well there's aspects of these
hyper-organized phases that certain
vibrations wear at all the other
vibrations it's just chaos you know in
the sand so osmosis collection of ideas
like a library of ideas and then more
recently it all started coming together
like it took eight years to gather the
puzzle pieces and yet find them and now
it's gonna take a few years to assemble
the puzzle pieces so we've been
assembling them for the last two years
but in the last few months it feels like
one of those big jigsaw puzzles where
the first 10% of the pieces are really
slow to come together but the last 10%
when 90% is done you just like zing zing
zing putting them all down fast so it's
all starting to come together in an
accelerated fashion right now some
pretty you're just doing me yeah what
does that mean what does it mean for
quantum gravity research to have the
jigsaw pieces coming down fast like what
does that look like for someone that's
lay that's not yeah well it means that
it's becoming it's it's it's rapidly
approaching a theory that will be
rigorous so a lot of internet videos and
a lot of papers out there published on
the internet that have equations but
that nobody in the physics community
agrees or appreciates them because
there's a lot of hand waving in that in
physics and mathematics
I'm not mathematics but in physics
there's hand waving where people plug
numbers to make it work or they make
conjectures that sound like they could
be true but who knows mathematics is
different mathematics you get proofs and
you're building it up by strict then so
what we want is a theory that doesn't
have a bunch of hand waving conjectures
in it or plugs we want a theory that is
undeniably empirically true like the way
a math equation is and and one of the
ways that we will get there is with
advanced computer simulation because
because it is a code it's a geometric
code we can simulate it in
supercomputers and so we're moving into
that phase now where the people we're
hiring for now in fact we're
interviewing right now is for motives
for advanced level level computer coders
that have very strong mathematics
backgrounds so as soon as we start doing
that what happens is either it's do or
die in other words if we're wrong yeah
these simulations will not simulate out
to be physically realistic right if
we're right they'll simulate out to be
physically realistic and if that happens
because the physical realism emerged
from a hyper rigorous mathematical
formalism that comes ultimately from the
gauge symmetry you know Lee lattice
algebras and comes with this strictly
reasonable you know rigorous code with
no plugs right yeah okay so then the
idea is that you can run advanced level
simulations that can showcase that your
emergence theory of space-time and
quantum mechanics can be you can
simulate out the quasi crystal the
the lattices out into what you think is
the these fundamental mathematical
equations that can then showcase what's
occurring in the physical world and that
that can be repeated over and over and
over again physically over the tax so
it's over like the laser show where
there's only over time does this physics
exist so even without the equations
which we will have those as well but the
simulation itself if you have a a
positron and electron interaction in the
simulation animation and it behaves
statistically just like quantum
mechanics says it should behave then you
have looked under the hood of quantum
mechanics and have found the reason for
the statistics in other words the
simulation produces exactly the
statistics then that means that the
statistics and the simulation or the
code are what we call and map isomorphic
to one another you know which is to say
that they may be they may look different
but they're absolutely the same thing
not not analogs of one another okay and
then there's there's still there's still
a lot more to talk about regarding what
you're doing with topological quantum
computing cold fusion and whatnot I'm
still very interested to talk to you
about the advancements in those fields I
do want to I do want to wrap and I want
to open up space also for the for the
rest of today's conversations that are
going to ensue so let's um let's do a
quick just give us a quick update on
topological quantum computing in cold
fusion like is that where did those land
on the priority level it's mostly the
emergence theory is like what is that
eighty percent and then two topological
it's computing and cold fusion or less
than it so word yeah we're going to
focus stand and yeah what were those two
are where those two at yeah so what gets
me excited and gets me to you know keep
pouring my energy and into this is you
know is service you know like why not
like just like things that we can do
that are high impact
that that make people have more fun and
have a more have people not be so mean
to one another at the end of the day and
so the two largest economies in the
world are energy and information but
energy eclipses information so the
energy economy is by far the largest the
second largest is information and so
these are these are clearly important
because as the internet grows as the
information economy grows it is the
fastest growing and hungriest beast yes
for electricity it is single-handedly
causing China and other countries to
begin construction of new coal mines and
you know and and again accelerating
global warming and we cannot rely on an
alternative energy source in this
current paradigm that is similarly
priced to fossil fuel the reason if you
think about it is because even if
windmill and solar technology were 10%
cheaper than fossil fuel technology what
are you gonna do about the trillions of
dollars invested in the global
infrastructure of fedexes airplane fleet
FedEx is car fleet every piece of
factory equipment trillions of dollars
in factory equipment based on burning
you know various forms of fossil fuels
somebody's got to pay for that and it's
not going to get paid for by some energy
technology technology that's five or ten
percent cheaper it needs to be an order
of magnitude cheaper to foot the bill
for a complete trashing and retrofitting
of the old massive investment into
fossil fuel energy technologies and so
there is no such clean energy technology
now on the horizon for that except for
one and that's low energy nuclear
reaction
technology this was formerly called cold
fusion so after 1989 there was this
period where the scientific community
who studied this decided that it's
probably fake like not real it was it
looked like it was real when the papers
came out by pons and Fleischmann but
then time went on and governments and
Institute's like MIT and others kept
working on it and nowadays it's known by
experts that it's real so low-energy
nuclear reaction is real but you have to
be a subject-matter expert if you got
somebody who's old school and they were
just a scientist who is exposed to the
information you know the papers 20 years
ago then they would still be in the past
what are you guys doing with low energy
nuclear so what we're doing is we're
applying things that we've learned in
these last 10 years for our space-time
theory to material science which is 23
orders of magnitude larger and scale at
the atomic scale and we're applying that
to the generation of energy via a
low-energy nuclear reaction which is if
it could be manifested and commercially
available it would be the energy
technology that's an order of magnitude
cheaper than fossil fuels wind or Sun or
any form of electric of electric city
generation known so then on the other
side of things is the the information
economy and all of the goodness that's
coming from it we haven't even seen the
tip of the iceberg of what the freedom
and flow and size of information and
computational power how it can help
people and how it can help alleviate
suffering but as you know we're reaching
the end of the party the Moore's Law
where we keep reducing the size of the
circuits it's now starting to bump in to
the limit at the atomic level and we're
eking out through new algorithms and
different ways a little bit more but we
are still reaching a limit so what's
going to have
then when we reach that limit does the
exponential expansion of digital you
know empowered technology start to you
know taper off like a like a bell curve
and top and quantum computing like as
though written by a Hollywood
screenwriter is quantum computing is
coming in to the rescue at right in the
nick of time it's under development by
Google Microsoft Intel IBM and China and
lots of other places in a big way in
very only in recent times and so of
those five in those five groups China
Intel IBM and Google are gambling on
what we call quantum computing okay
Microsoft stands alone as the only big
company gambling on topological quantum
computing you guys are too and us ok and
a few others and and a topological
quantum computer would do what so
topological quantum computer will do
what is a great question because it
allows me to remind us that science
today does not know what quantum
mechanics is they know the statistics
but it's still mysterious as to what the
hell is really going on and this is
called the field that it's an area of
the interpretations of quantum mechanics
so you have the Copenhagen
interpretation you have the you know the
the the bomb interpretation you have all
these interpretations but that all this
the statistics which is just what
quantum mechanics is matches all of
their interpretations and some of the
interpretations have wildly different
philosophical and ontological right
implications so my opinion then is that
reality itself the space-time code is a
topological quantum computer but we have
to reject all former baggage that comes
with the word computer or computation
because that comes from 20th century
notions of of linear
binary computation your mind does not
compute like that your mind can compute
what's two plus two
right yeah you just computed for but
just because you compute doesn't mean
you are a computer you're a computer or
you're not a computer and and so if
reality is a topological network just
cutting to the chase it's a neural
network a topological quantum computer
but it's almost a magical neural network
because it's using the bizarre spooky
weirdness of quantum mechanics where a
thing can be here and then here but it
was never at any other place in between
just weird like teleporting yeah and
these other sorts of ideas that two
things can be connected or entangled
such that a change here instantly makes
a change here with nothing with no time
there's no time for this to influence
that and quantum computing does not do
only topological quantum computing
employs some of the concepts from
quantum mechanics that are weird
yes but topological quantum computing
goes kind of even more exotic and so
we're here in southern california in the
world's epicenter for topological
quantum computing it was invented by
alexey sidorov at Caltech
you know half hour from here and the and
Microsoft put in huge you know tens of
millions of dollars into an institute
called Microsoft Microsoft station Q
it's at UC Santa Barbara where they
collaborate with the university so
that's where there's this huge amount of
work being done there with you know
collaboration with Microsoft and then
Caltech so so yeah we're we're kind of
in the in the backyard of topological
quantum computing and then at time
allocation to those other two compared
to the emergence theory where you guys
had well we've got we've got about 15 or
so scientists all PhDs working on the
low-energy nuclear reaction technology
and in the next six months I'm going to
begin funding the startup we've already
set up the startup but to start
recruiting and organizing it is
something I'll be doing in the later
part of this year for the quantum
computing company so the quantum
computing company is called e what so so
we have emergence so the quantum
computing small e you can merchants
right and then the energy company is
called emergent energy so we really like
the word emergence yeah and so our
theory unification there is of course
emergence theory so okay and your time
dedicated to those other two compared to
I would say that I would say that a
hundred percent of my time right now is
dedicated to the unification theory
because that's it and that encompasses
the other three sub components there
will be genetic technologies there will
be superconducting technologies many
technologies will come out of this
theory if it's true right if it is
physically true but I want to spend time
on these two other things for two
reasons one is they will help the world
they'll do good in the world and two is
they will bring evidential experimental
support to the theory because the theory
if it's rigorous and predictive and if
it has at its core the foundation of
this philosophical underpinnings like
we've been talking about it can lead to
a new worldview that legitimizes some of
the claims of people who have had
psychic experiences indigenous peoples
experiences may not legitimize all of
their stories and the metaphors but
it'll legitimize that and it could it
could make a new world paradigm which is
really kind of like the unification of
spirit and matter in science where both
of those words are so loaded like matter
represents the word matter we can say
incorporates them you know physics and
quantum mechanics and what we can
understand about nature you know through
mathematics and then the world of spirit
is this ineffable world of these
experiences within consciousness and
experiencing other consciousnesses and
what if those two things were
placeholders like partially dirty or
incorrect stories that are placeholders
at a table to be replaced by a much more
reasonable fully unifying new viewpoint
yep so grand unification theory is not
only for all the different technologies
that could that is gonna catalyze the
emergence of but it's also for us to mix
together the spirit with science more
effectively and understand yeah the
reality that we're in yes Clete this has
been an awesome round too I feel like
yeah we did a great job on packing yeah
everything there still again there's
still so much nuance here I would have
spent like a whole nother hour on you
know coffee crystals and trying to
understand those better and all the
other work that quantum gravity research
is doing but this is will make a good of
Round three when we come and revisit or
the next update thanks for doing your
homework because you prepared excellent
questions and you really understand the
talks I appreciate that yeah I'm
following the source better than I'm
following quasi crystals because you
guys are doing great work it really does
require people that are in like 15 20
your depth in math or physics to get
this stuff and be able to test it
empirically with the simulations it's a
very interesting stuff what you're doing
and hopefully what the benevolence is
channeling through everyone is
here for for a reason to alter our
trajectory in a more positive direction
yes right yeah
clue thank you so much for coming off
around to really appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below in the episode let us
know what you're thinking do check out
quantum gravity research or check out
the link in the bio and also talk to
your friends your families co-workers
people online on social media about
grand unification theory you're talking
more about this and what it could really
unlock for us blending together
space-time quantum mechanics and
actually understanding those also talk
more about source and aura Boros talk
more about what we're talking about
there what is the ultimate TV ology of
this human experiment and also go check
out all the cool videos that corner
gravity research has made about the
point about the quasi crystal because
all the videos that are up do a really
good job at explaining what they're
talking about so check those out those
are all on the YouTube channel and on
the website both and also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders and organizations around the
world that you believe and support them
and help them grow support clients grab
research support simulation our links
are below to our patreon crypto-currency
paypal links all down there help us
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to Topanga for these interviews
and also go build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we'll see you soon peace
- oh yes
yeah I'm Dan so much higher that's good
that's